alors attendez c'est pas fini mathieu il
a été formidable matthieu protard à son
égard comme un film pour miss hathaway
ah oui c'est vrai c'est un match où il
est encore émue regarder franchement
nous avons mathieu chérir galilée pas
bien oui même tellement il était
tellement déçu c'est vrai mentionne mais
nomment qu'on le voit comme ça mais ça a
duré très longtemps
ouais et on a vraiment cru qu'il était
mort mais il est là il est dans le
public idées ont d'ailleurs dominique
bull le comédien
m
c'est rare qu'on est bien et hégémonie
on a on n'a pas encore la fin de magnéto
certainement dominique bellamy l'hebdo
merci dominique merci merci merci et
alors je vais vous dire mathieu en fait
je lui ai dit que le lendemain n'est en
fait que le lendemain un mathieu que
c'était une caméra cachée et un rien
c'était là dominique hambourg est avec
nous pour vous asseoir sa comédie qui se
baladent sur pattes on dirait qu'ils
soient les 38 le garder les bras dans
les poches ou akbar il y réécrit les
beaux gosses ça va mal et je lui ai dit
que le lendemain que c'est une caméra
cachée et pendant tout ce temps en fait
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé vous avez même
appelez vos amis et tout ça on va la
regarder pour vous reprendre
vous reprenez vos esprits regardez la
fin c'était dans la loge quand je dit à
mathieu que c'est une caméra cachée
regardez c'est dur
moi ce que je sais de sortir de là parce
que tu es monde est capturé dans la mer
tu as fait une connerie j'ai essayé de
trouver des solutions avec les clients
ont été reportés comme une ordure mais
en fait c est parce que trop d'émotions
du continue aujourd'hui
au contraire je suis là pour t'aider
c'est un fou ce matin je te dis que je
m'étais dit que te sortir de là
franchement les séries mais comme ça ce
que je suis autorisé hier soir tu as
fait le canada fier d'être d'abord
pasqua mais j'ignore quel gâchis on se
rend compte des notions d une tendinite
ne soit deux au cul les toits et encore
de diego hier je comprends que tu sois
rennais 1 hier et j'espère les soulager
des balades et puis un panache c'est
bien le nôtre mais ça c'est qu'ils y
croient que moi outre avatar mais comme
toujours à tous pareils il a dîné tu
parles d'un groupe mon dieu je pense
c'est pourquoi quand tu casses la gueule
avec concerto de caméras cachées le mec
qui tombe il est qu'un médecin il sans
doute sans spécifique ultime américain
qui démontrerait un drame a fait du
conte propagation ses pronos exactement
10 nues j'ai cru qu'il eu des morts ce
que j'ai mis la main dessus comme une
infographie et je sortais pas de vous et
je me suis dit homicide involontaire on
a reçu d'une barre qui a aucun témoin
moi je fais toi et les empreintes
partout autour d'une barre comporte mais
tellement convaincu les jeux passé la
nuit en garde à vue lundi à évacuer les
eaux tde mobiliser toute évolution de la
ligue les ventes de culture le beau
temps est de la partie
je pense qu'on est macho jeune et qui a
été exceptionnel j'avais le match que tu
avais jamais oublier que c'était moi
c'est ouf
ce n'est jamais la chine pour son jeu
mais comment il a eu son moment il ya
des histoires 5 at elle ajouté
je refuse de prendre ces jeunes filles
prisonniers quand il est à fond ménashé
tout de même mais costaud d'ipo que
j'aime bien les gouttes parce que tu es
toi tu le sais tous les côtés dans
machete
ah la la
mon doublé et maintenant je crois que tu
m'as tu crois que tu m'aimes encore plus
qu'avant
ouais ouais mais ce qu'ils veulent ça
c'est le lendemain ouais si c'est dur
oui mais non mais ça ils te regardent
sont pas contre mais pendant 10 minutes
j'ai cru que j'avais un homicide
involontaire sur les bras non j'allais
prendre 50 prison c'est à vous voir
contre la mienne je peux rien faire
n'est pas de caméra y'a rien je me
voyais partir au poste et voilà ta vie
bascule je suis rentré j'ai exposé en
sanglots dans la voiture je me suis fait
flasher d'ailleurs si tu vas le payer
mais fait flasher si windows et après
j'ai appelé jury vérité j'ai appelé bas
mon grand frère quand j'appelais marc
olivier fogiel
ouais j'étais en pleurs une vie calme
toi calme-toi vient la maison qu'est ce
qui se passe je dit juste c'est un
monstre un monstre et lui m'a dit mais
je raconte l'histoire et me dit mais si
les gens savaient c'est un puits
l'équilibré
les numéros à la télé si les gens
savaient il m'a dit je ne faut pas que
tu ailles l'antenne lendemain c'est fini
c'est fini c'est lille dénonce pas le
lendemain dit luc tu arrêtes tout est
dit que c'est fini et dans la nuit il
m'a dit je te présente les dupond
moretti qui traînent avocat pénaliste
parce que si dans la nuit fait une
hémorragie interne ou quand il faut que
tu ailles maintenant voir il était deux
heures du matin faute et avoir un
pénaliste faut que tu ailles la police
je suis j'en peux plus et tout ça je
suis rentré j'ai faut pas faire ça j'ai
pris des des débats là d un truc
relaxant ouais c'est ça j'ai pas dîné
tous ont serré la main et m'a dit je
veux arrêter l'émission julie faut
concevoir l'humour et les textos dans la
nuit pour dire tu as été super bravo
frères brown
je me suis dit plus jamais je peux faire
des missions avec vous même si une
guerre va bien même si le gars va bien
j'ai vu votre vrai visage
j'ai vu que si ça se passe mal vous êtes
là pires ordures du monde
c'est une caméra cachée connard
es tu sais comme je t'aime maintenant
ouais ça va mieux oui ça va mieux mais
je reconnais j'ai très mal vécu là on
peut parler deux secondes ce que tu as
dit sur les autres car ça va a alors
l'émotion est beaucoup d'émotion on
négocie on dit des conneries ben voila
j'ai besoin qu'a eu beaucoup d'émotions
comme ça a dit beaucoup de conneries je
pense que c'est le moment des quatre
tirs ah ben je pense que là il ya une
bonne ambiance pour rigoler